[Music]
[Music]
smells like queef in here
all right
time to hand out the party favors
[Music]
things that make you go
[Music]
hope you weren't planning on not
exploding tonight
you can dish it out
or can you take it
[Music]
ready to be part of throat rip history
[Music]
the old reverse throat rib the holy
grail of throat ribs
they said it couldn't be done
but we did it didn't we a dead piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
looks like our little barbecue's about
to begin
hope you like your meat well done
let it begin
tonight it ends
20 years ago we were exiled
spit out
left for dead
we are the forgotten
the discarded
we're ghosts
tomorrow the children of the world
will receive a very special presence
not a sweater
not a bean baby
not a shiny new trike no this present is
something far more interesting
this present
it melts faces it makes your eyes pour
out of your sockets like water
closes throats mcboyd's bowels
kills by the millions
and it all could have been avoided
but the united states
does not negotiate with patriots
well [ __ ] them
they may have forgotten the hell that
they put us through
but tomorrow
they will remember our names
[Music]
sure there's a bogey approach
from the groover
[Music]
take him out fire
fire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
find him
[Music]
damn it fall back
[Music]
[Music]
you